our company name is called pine biotech
we're a biotechnology company located in
the u.s and new orleans in louisiana
but we are a technology transfer company
that stems out of university of haifa
specifically the center
for bioinformatics called the tower
bioinformatics research center
the center was started to make
bioinformatics more accessible
design algorithms as well as make them
useful for people that do not have
extensive bioinformatics background and
expertise
and what we've identified as a team is
that there is a
growing need in training individuals to
be effective at utilizing
the wide arrange of bioinformatics tools
and apply them in a meaningful way to
research
challenges that are pressing in the area
of biomedical research
agriculture and biotechnology and so as
a result in 2017 we started a program
that
up till date has over 15 000
participants from around the world
we have a lot of content that we have
refined with the help of many different
curriculum reviewers and work together
with a number of
highly specialized universities around
the world
organizations that are training the next
generation of bioinformaticians
and working with statewide and
country-wide
organizations that are designed to help
elevate the level of biomedical research
around the country
including the louisiana biomedical
research network
including our partners in different high
schools colleges
research labs and industry
and so as a result we have really
identified these three pillars
of our program which is access to big
data in a meaningful way so solving the
problem
of computational resources so that
anyone from the comfort of their home
can utilize complex tools apply them to
big data and get meaningful insights
the second aspect is mentorship it's not
easy from the comfort of your home
to really know what you're doing and so
that's why we brought in
a number of experienced and highly
qualified mentors that are ready to
assist
anyone go from knowing about
bioinformatics
to actually applying bioinformatics and
the third pillar is obviously training
so we provide
resources that are making the
computational background the algorithmic
component
training in coding and different
elements of
bioinformatics as well as biology and
biomedicine and biotechnology how
do you apply data science to these
challenges so we merge those together
in our omics logic curriculum